is that we could talk about Christmas
for hours but I'm distracted by the
makings of a cocktail cocktail at
Christmas everyone okay well I like to
give Britain a little tip every now and
again so you need to find yourself a
sheath right now this is if you go to
the really posh cocktail bars you get
these incredible ice cubes at their
hand-carved oh no no no we go get a
water pond right and we just split it
and we peel it off and we get a lovely
round what they do at the posh places
then we're gonna make a Christmas
Negroni
[Applause]
groaning
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Negroni I won't eat think of it as
medicine right okay if you've got every
one of us has someone a bit boring a bit
sort of dodgy come in to the Christmas
party there's always one so then what
you do is you take this leg Roni aka
medicine medicine right and it turns
people that are a bit problematic and
boring into interesting people 20 mils
of Campari
20 mils of vermouth Russell which we've
sent it with a little cinnamon and
Christmas fair yes and then we have a
little gin a little bit of Clementine to
get you guys are you ready for this I'm
like come on man if you don't become
more interesting I don't know what's
going to happen okay pass it down is
like school like a Christmas Carol and
we are Scrooge because like a Merry
Christmas everybody
six-hundred Tiny Tim
okay oh come on oh that is time the
world changing although I need a judge
of whether or not it's delicious
no I like that it has just enough
Christmas in it here's the thing no
that's very good that's right you wants
it you wants it home I drank from this
side so you can drink from that side you
can just another side no you say what
you think is this like feeding a gremlin
after midnight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah a Christmas to remember
that was the Christmas Oh
you
[Music]